wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
was brauchen wir noch
wir müssen die balken besonnen mitnehmen
habe ich schon und die fußbälle
sie liegen hinter dir ich habe zwei neue
gekauft und wirst du zum grill getränke
und hütchen zum trainiert tollen fußball
teuer
nein ich war super billig ein ball hat
für eure 99 gekostet weniger als die
getränke verpflegung ist immer am
teuersten einigung bereit
na ja keine fußballschuhe mit sketchen
welche chance hast du nicht schlecht ist
er viel zu gut für uns optimal 12 laster
an verbände irgendeiner verletzte
gekümmert
eric als wir beim letzten mal am knie
verletzt ich konnte zwei tage nicht
laufen
die schulklassen vielen dank perfekt ich
find's super dass du mit kommst los
[Musik]